Imamo pravna pravila koja su ona pravila
koja imaju uređeno funkcionisanje države
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanja države
koja su podložna čelima subordinacije
i koordinacije.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti koji imamo u državnom
daju na različitim stepenima vlasti.
A kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo saradnju.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se, jel da, zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima,
pravimo se sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade i kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svaki lički.
Znači taj državni aparat čine
samo neki ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime i za račun države.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određeni poslovi.
Dakle,
imate potrebu za državnim službenim licem,
date mu da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radnu.
Ja se trudim
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim,
ne da se držim tih definicija službenika,
nego najprostije moguće da vam objasnim.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao, daš ga jednom
državnom službenom licu i kažeš evo ti,
napravi, radi to,
to je tvoja nadležnost, bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekako funkcionalna,
to uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih organa,
Ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno lice, da li oni rade isto?